[Music]
homie look what I become
okay so we have a special guest here
with us you know what I love about this
podcast is one week we'll have a guest
and there'll be a group that's very
happy and there'll be a group that's
very unhappy then the unhappy group a
couple weeks later are incredibly happy
and a happy group is now unhappy it's
always great so you can you know they're
making everybody happy today's guest is
going to piss a lot of people off and
they're gonna say they've already seen
why are you having someone like that but
let me let me formally introduce Our
Guest here today uh Jeffrey Ross tuben
Jeff or Jeffrey Ross Truman is an
American lawyer author blogger long time
legal analyst for CNN during the Iran
Contra affair tuben served as an
associate Council on the investigation
in the Department of Justice he moved
from government into practice into a law
uh full-time writing during the 90s when
he published his first books he wrote
the New York he wrote for the New Yorker
from 1993 to 2020 that's 27 years he was
fired after an on-camera during a zoom
video conference call uh with his
co-workers he continued to serve as a
legal analyst for CNN for two years
tuben has written several books we just
found that out of the eight books he's
written six of them are New York Times
bestsellers but again who's counting
including accounts on the 1970s Patty
Hearst kidnapping and her time with the
SLA the O.J Simpson murder case and
Clinton Lewinsky scandal the latter two
adapted into a television series of FX
american crime stories with the Simpsons
uh case Premiere in 2016 is that the one
with Cuba good on Jr yeah which was
which was pretty wild a few other things
you need to know about him that uh on
both sides one side
um
I don't know how many years ago this was
three or four years ago or five years
ago when he's on there confidently
you're saying Roe v Wade is done it was
so bad that uh
forget about Jim Acosta who else was
making fun of you you know the comedian
uh what's his name uh John uh oh John
Oliver
I'm telling my daughter this no that's
not what it is but you were like nope
it's over so you called it it happened
you were right your peers didn't agree
with you and you're not somebody that
was for it that it was happening but you
said it was going to happen at the same
time you know we have to give you credit
uh uh I've been in sales for since 21
years old okay so I've done a lot of uh
you know what's that 23 years
um I think we're on the same page that
we miss conference calls more than zooms
because when it was on conference calls
people had no clue what you and I were
doing unfortunately zooms were a little
bit more uh uh uh uncomfortable a more
revealing of what we're doing so
obviously the whole world find out uh
what happened with you that was a story
that was trending SNL was all over the
place but whether you like whether you
don't like him whether you agree with
them whether you don't agree with them
you're an absolute heavyweight in a
media space the last 30 years you've
done a lot of great work and it's great
to have you on a podcast well it is a
thrill to be here thank you so much for
having me so let's let's address the
elephant in the room and then we'll get
into all the stories here so first when
that happened you're saying you had no
clue the camera was on you had none of
that stuff and you've talked about this
multiple multiple times my question
isn't about your apology you've already
addressed and actually like the way you
did it there's some people that didn't
like it you just kind of said look as a
lawyer I can't even defend this I can't
even say anything about it I just this
is what I did I'm Manning up I screwed
up you know it is what it is I wish they
would have kept me but I understand
their reasoning these guys brought us
back some people said why would you
bring him back you know he should have
never had the job people for lesser
things were fired you know Megan Kelly's
been critical of you a lot of other
people have been critical of you but you
owned up to it you just said this is
what I did my question is what do you
talk about during therapy for something
like that
um
look uh
where to start
um you know I did something wrong period
And I am more sorry than I can say
um to everyone involved the people on
the call my former colleagues people who
trusted me as a journalist
um I've been working to restore my
reputation since then
um I you know as I say I don't make
excuses I only make apologies
um I'd like to think that I mean as as
we say in school as we used to say in
school you know I know this is on my
permanent record but I like to think
it's not the only thing on my permanent
record
and you know all all I could do is you
know offer a complete apology and try to
get on with the work that I do I would I
would say this part uh from my
perspective okay
um I don't think you can be in media for
three decades without having some dirt
that comes out on you whether it's going
to be a DUI you know you remember who
was a guy that was the best Monday Night
Football guy and then he got a DUI
leaving a restaurant Al Michaels Al
Michael's any address I got something
embarrassing to say I got a DUI cop
pulled me over it doesn't matter who you
are whether it's politics media all this
stuff you're eventually going to do
something that's going to be screwed up
yours happened to be something that
every boy has gone through what you've
gone through except most people get
caught with their parents it's not on a
zoom so you're like you're like the goat
status of of getting you know you know
in the space that you went but the
question I have for you is a very
different question I run an insurance
company we've licensed 45 000 agents we
sold the company last year but one of
the things that I had to learn as a CEO
when I ran an office with 66 agents I
know everyone's dirt and it wasn't big
dirt and then all of a sudden one of our
best guys got a divorce and also one of
our guys got a DUI and all of a sudden
one of our guys you know we love this
guy cocaine issues boom we lost him
another guy went through marital issues
another guy went through drug issues not
and then eventually I was like why is
this happening and I'm like listen
everybody sins in a different way
everybody's going to do some stuff that
they're going to do unfortunately some
of them are going to be Republican
humiliating and we got to kind of go
through it and it seemed like the bigger
and bigger the company got the more
stories like this happened was there a
part of you because one guy called me
one time and he says do you know what
that guy is doing do you know how what
that other guy's doing I said listen
you claim you're a Christian I do well
listen man you may want to not be that
judgmental because in about a couple
years it's going to be your turn and
you're going to want people to be a
little bit more gentler on you okay when
it comes down to your turn did at any
point for you did you kind of sit there
and say [__] this is pretty embarrassing
and I've been the one that's kind of
been hard on that guy and this guy and
that guy and this guy did you buy
yourself I'm not talking wife and kids
and all that stuff in college just you
versus your mono you know like yourself
did you say you know what as much as I
don't like that guy yeah you know that
guy also did something here and that guy
also did something here I guess none of
us are perfect I have to really work on
becoming more forgiving because now I
want people to be gentler on me did you
ever go through that process uh short
answer yes I I think
um you know when you have sinned
publicly you are aware of others who
have sinned publicly I think one thing
that I felt
um I I don't want to say
positively about is you know even back
to the days when I was a prosecutor I
was never the
um lock them up and throw away the key
kind of person and and that's not the
kind of journalist I've been I I have
written about people who have made
mistakes who have come back from them
and
um written positively about that so you
know my view has always been that you
know if you acknowledge what you did if
you you know try to make amends try to
apologize then you get another chance I
I as as people have said to me you don't
get a third chance and and I'm very
aware of that in my own life but
um I I I I I I don't feel like of all
the things you can criticize you know
accuse me of and I think there are a lot
hypocrisy is not one of them I'm not
someone who has always been you know one
strike in your kind of person and um so
in that respect
um I I think my reaction is consistent
quick follow-up right there I've watched
you on CNN for 20 plus years so
um one thing that I'm obsessed with
Jeffrey is the concept of Legacy right
we talked about reputation I started my
show
um when I started interviewing
Millionaires and billionaires and
financial advisors and I asked them all
right after you doing all the saving and
all the investing and everything and the
budgeting and the and the and the
gifting and the philanthropy I'm like
What's Next what's next and like it's
just it's Legacy it's Legacy planning
they actually call it estate planning
Legacy planning
um so the question of legacy is what my
one of my favorite uh people that I've
ever read their books is John Bogle Jack
Bogle the founder of Vanguard and he
said when I die my one wish is that I
die with my legacy intact so you you've
been working in media 30 years right so
Pat reads your bio and of course you've
done all this work six-time New York
bestseller and then it's like oh by the
way you got golf jacking off on a zoom
call by the way like that's part of your
legacy that's part of your reputation
you know like the famous joke is like
you can build a thousand Bridges and uh
you [__] one goat you're no longer a
bridge builder you're a goat [__] yada
yada so very very interesting I didn't
know that joke
now I'll never forget
yeah to use a metaphor some call you the
goat so yeah I mean even if an urban
dictionary there's a like you're
familiar with this I I'm familiar with
Urban Dictionary I wasn't aware that I'm
now am I you go to tubing how wonderful
if you get caught on Zoom so like this
is part of your legacy yeah I'm going
somewhere yeah okay hold on so uh but we
also understand that America likes a
comeback story we talk about this all
the time is that like this is America
you get Second Chances you didn't kill
anybody dude like you didn't you didn't
do anything like felonious like you got
caught doing what dudes do you just
happened to do it [__] an
embarrassing fashion you know it's rough
um
my question is everyone's gonna have
that lowest point in their life this is
clearly your lowest point
what's your comeback story what's your
strategy how can someone deal with the
lowest part of their life the most
embarrassing thing that could ever
happen to you and make a comeback and
own it and be on podcast and be like
yeah you know I did it how can someone
deal with that
well I guess my my two two ways
um one is acknowledge and apologize not
you know one of the things that uh you
know I I often thought you know I've
covered a lot of
um political scandals and and one of the
lines that always
um irritated me was
um but people would say well I I'm sorry
if you were offended which is not a real
apology that that's like blaming you I'm
sorry because I'm sorry because I did
something wrong because there's no
excuse so so in that respect you know
not to try to equivocate about the
wrongdoing is just to completely
acknowledge that there is no excuse and
it was it was wrong the the second part
is to get back to work is to do the work
that you do and fortunately I was
allowed by CNN by
um Simon and Schuster who Pope published
this book that to to do the work that I
do and do it well and
um
that's that's the the way to come back I
mean I'm incredibly proud of homegrown
this book I this book is the best work I
can do and I think the reaction to it
has has been terrific and that's that's
the way to
um to try to come back you know there's
a there's a quick follow-up there's
there's you know there's a camp out
there that would say never apologize
never never say you're sorry
own it you did what you did do not
apologize don't even only like there's
that can't I thought we were going to
talk about Donald Trump yeah
what would you say to that camp that's
saying never apologize that's not me I
mean I I apologize because I think it's
the right thing to do and
um you know I I I you know I can't speak
for other people and
um obviously
um you know some some people that that
that's their approach I can only do you
know what what I think is right for me
um and I I we would it would it would
never even have occurred to me not to
apologize so I I want to get right into
it if we can I want to get into his
shoes is what I want to know I'd like to
talk about this one
[Music]
take us to the issue but I'll say one
thing I mean this sincerely I appreciate
your saying acknowledge and apologize
and get back to work because I agree
with you when people say I'm sorry you
were offended it puts on other people
it's funny I've always thought that when
I heard that and the other thing that I
get that I can't stand when I hear is
but this is not who I am yes it was for
that moment and you need to own it and
just move on from it and I really
applaud that because it didn't mean you
no longer had a Harvard law degree it
didn't mean that you were no longer a
classmate of Elena Kagan didn't mean you
no longer had six out of eight New York
Times bestsellers and you were a
brilliant legal mind on these issues
that didn't change and I appreciate when
you you come out on the other side and
say hey there's something more I can do
here and there's something I can do it's
like you know one of the BIOS I
appreciated was Chuck Colson now you
didn't commit a felony and a cover-up
and all that was the goo that was there
but he he basically discovered a current
in prison reform and to do something
else good without a law license because
he was disbarred and I think there's far
too few of those stories in America and
there's a little tiny thread of that in
what you just said so Tom when was the
first time you were caught all right
Grandma Thanksgiving he already said it
all right all right okay phenomenal
let's get right into it okay thank you
Jeffrey so we I got some issues I'm
going to go through obviously a lot of
current events I do want to make it
clear guys we're going to put the link
below to the book that's here homegrown
Timothy McVeigh and the rise of right
wink extremism we're going to talk about
that obviously on today's podcast if we
can put it there
um but before we get into that current
events okay
um
when you said uh uh Roe v Wade okay now
I'm telling you and you said you think
this is gonna happen no I know it's done
it's over it's this and it's like what
is this guy talking about it was
discouraging to a lot of people and then
boom it happens what's it because in
your mind you're sitting there saying
these three seats presidents come and go
but these three seats you know six to
three or five to four this stays for 20
30 years right when you made a comment
like that about Roe v Wade and then
right before midterms I don't know what
the timeline was six weeks before
midterms or whatever it was when they
you know made the whole thing you know
last June yeah and it was supposed to be
what a red wave and it ended up not
being a red way because America's like
listen man I would have been a red wave
but this thing that you guys did
probably not some on the left and the
right it's not like it's just the left
issue you know both sides what made you
be so confident at the time to say I
think this is going to happen well you
know I've I've covered the intersection
of Law and politics for for my my entire
career and you know abortion has been
the most contentious issue between and
frankly it is between left and right in
this country and you know you have to go
back to
um the 2016 campaign and remember Donald
Trump as a private citizen was open
about being pro pro-choice in favor of
abortion rights so when he's running for
the Republican nomination he had to
convince the Evangelical community in
particular that he was trustworthy on
their issues and so when he um
ran for president he essentially
outsourced the issue of judicial
confirmations to a guy named Leonard Leo
in the federal society and they made a
list of the judges that they were that
the president that if Trump won he was
going to appoint to the Supreme Court
and those judges were all clearly
identified with the um anti-rovey Wade
position and this was an extremely
effective thing that Trump did to
ingratiate himself with the Republican
party because most of the Republican
party at this point is in an
anti-abortion position so you know
Donald Trump said during the campaign
if I win I am going to appoint judges
who who will vote to overturn Roe versus
Wade and what I think he meant by that
was if he won he was going to appoint
judges who would vote to overturn Roe v
Ware I mean I mean and
um he appointed the three the three
justices
um Gorsuch Kavanaugh Barrett
and and they did what was what was
expected of them
um so
um it was not any great you know
like uh prediction of mine it was just
listening and watching what was going on
and that and it was it was predictable
and it's it's so I know you're saying
it's predictable a lot of people on the
right thought it was predictable but why
is it so many people on the left didn't
see that being predictable well I I I
think um you know Roe v Wade was 1973.
um there have there were a lot of
um republican nominees since 1973 who
turned out to be
um supportive of Roe v Wade you know
think about it John Paul Stevens
appointed in 1973 by Gerald Ford
Anthony Kennedy and Sandra Day O'Connor
appointed by Ronald Reagan
um David souter appointed by George
Herbert Walker Bush all of whom wound up
being pro-abortion rights on the court
so I think
um there was uh perhaps some uh sense
that well the you know when push comes
to shove the the Trump appointees won't
won't vote to overturn Roe v Wade I
recognized I think correctly that the
politics have really changed that that
abortion uh was so Central to Trump's uh
appeal to the right in his in his
campaign that there was just no way he
was going to point some any justices who
would wind up voting for Roe v Wade so
that the it really is about the
evolution of the Republican party that
you know in the 70s and 80s there were a
lot of pro-choice Republicans that is
not the case anymore uh particularly of
among Republicans who vote in primaries
and and the different that abortion
rights has really become a a party line
issue in the way it did it wasn't in the
past and to to kind of reference the the
story paths basically identifying was it
was a CNN panel hosted by Jim Acosta
you're on their legal analyst a handful
of other people and they're playing a
John Oliver clip and you were blunt
you're saying Rover's weight is now dead
done official this is in 2019 I believe
well yeah it was after Trump was elected
okay whenever it was but yeah clearly
years this year years ahead of your time
you nailed it you called your shot
and the way that you know how to say
that facts don't care about your
feelings the way that you said it was so
blunt and so to the point people were
shocked on the panel John Oliver who he
references like
um Jeffrey tube is the kind of guy that
he's going to tell his kid you know not
hey I'm just gonna send my dog out to
pastures like we took him to the park we
shot him in the face he's dead now right
like just blunt so what kind of backlash
did you get from people internally in
your in your world saying tubing how the
hell could you say something like that
it's offensive not really I mean I
didn't get I didn't get any backlash I
mean one of the things that I think
people don't understand that you know I
I I'm trying to remember I mean I worked
at CNN for 20 years I so I can't you
know account for every day but you know
once you establish that you know what
you're talking about uh people don't
tell you you know I I imagine people
said wow you know that was pretty
definitive you really think that's you
really think that's true and um you know
frankly
one of the things I don't love about
cable news in terms of my own uh my own
experience there is the whole prediction
business I mean it's very nice that you
were focusing on
um a correct prediction that I made but
I made some plenty of wrong predictions
most most prominently and one that I I
have thought about a lot over the years
was that Hillary Clinton was going to
beat Donald Trump in 2016. and ever
since then the fact that I was so wrong
about that has made me very cautious
about counting Trump out at any point in
any in under any circumstances even now
um you know I am very aware of how wrong
I was in 2016. I was a lot of company in
being wrong but that's you know and and
um you know I I just think
um
humility is really called for in turn
terms of political predictions in this
country
and you know and that goes for 2024 as
well right now with everything that's
going on with the election okay you're
seeing the scientists you're seeing
Trump you're seeing RFK you're seeing
vivec you're seeing you know obviously
Biden Newsome was on Hannity all this
stuff a year from the Republican uh uh
debate I'm sorry uh the general election
um
Republican versus Democrat when they
face each other who do you think is
going to be on that stage do you think
it is going to be a Biden trump it
certainly looks that way yeah do you
think there's any chance Newsom gets in
there anything you're saying zero chance
zero chance tell me why why do you think
because because I mean unless Biden
withdraws now that now there is no
chance that Newsome runs against Biden
wow well against no I totally agree with
the against part I agree that the
against but do you think okay did you
see him on Hannity I did not see I did
not see him by the way he showed up he
represented and and to me if you think
about uh uh a guy I left California
because of Newsom you know because of
those policies so I'm not somebody
that's sitting here saying oh you know
great with these policies I can't say
that part but if I were to say
um if I have a choice between a Newsome
or a Biden going on meeting with the
Enemy or anybody else representing the
big stage
Newsome looks presidential Biden looks
like he's passed out so wouldn't
Democrats want more a Newsome than a
Biden okay
let me qualify please what what I was
saying I am assuming I mean Joe Biden
has declared for re-election I mean he
is a candidate
um assuming he remains a candidate
there's zero chance Newsom will run it
will will run against him if
um Biden for some reason were to will
were to fall down fall down some stairs
break his hip you know what happens to
people in their 80s yeah
um then um then definitely I think
Newsom might run but uh and then it
would be a free-for-all I mean there
would be a lie you know the vice
president would run Open primary yeah it
would be there would be half a dozen
candidates within a couple weeks but you
know every every sign I have is that
Biden is going to remain the candidate I
think he's going to be a strong
candidate for re-election but
um and it's going to be a strong
candidate yeah we do why do you think
well first of all most most incumbents
get reelected it is unusual I mean Jimmy
Carter lost Donald Trump lost but uh
senior lost yeah
um the the senior loss so it's it's it
but but most candidates get reelected if
the economy remains in in a good place
um if abortion is I think it will will
remain a very big voting issue
especially for uh moderates and
Independence there's a big difference
between Donald Trump and and Joe Biden
on abortion in particular and if the
country is doing well economically you
know I mean you know no candidate
um or let me put it every candidate has
has problems
um Joe Biden's problem is that he's old
and uh but you know the countries gotten
used to them and he's not going gonna
he's not gonna overcome that problem by
becoming younger but if he maintains the
level of activity and involvement that
he has now I think he's going to be a
strong candidate I mean so I'll uh um
from a perspective of you know the
approval rating one of the lowest ever
approval ratings he's got right uh even
as a person let's just say if you got a
guy on your side and you're a republican
you're like that's my president but he's
got that kind of an approval rating man
I'm concerned about putting this guy in
as my starter you're as a democratic
side you got a low approval rating the
percentage of Democrats that don't want
you to run the people on media MSNBC CNN
that also don't want this guy to run
they would like him to step aside and
have somebody else run it's not like
it's just a republican Fox News or you
know Breitbart or whoever these guys are
saying that it's people on both sides
are saying by the way I have to be
honest with you if I'm a republican I
would much rather Biden Ronda Newsome
run I don't want no Newsome run Newsome
I think that's it I I think that's let
me give you my argument I want to hear
from you I want you to push back that's
why you're here I don't want you to
agree so so so for me I think one of the
things that some of the Independents
respected about Trump they're like where
is the meeting who wants to do it CNN
I'll come that's enemy territory MSNBC
I'll come 60 minutes I'll come then I'll
come in when the criticism what Obama
was like he did that one Bill O'Reilly
thing and that was it right but that's
Obama Biden's not Obama Obama can get
away with that because it's Obama Biden
he doesn't meet with the Enemy Newsome
went and sat with Hannity Hannity is
good friends with Trump and he handled
it that's got to be something where
you're like if this guy is willing to go
there
sit calm no notes zero notes in his hand
hand you know you have to see it it's
very impressive from tejed on that way
I'm sitting there saying listen coach
let's can you put me here like I'm I can
really do this thing here I think
Republicans would fear more a guy like
him than Biden but obviously you
disagree with that Alexa yeah well first
of all you know you have to remember I
think how little most Americans follow
politics Gavin Newsom is probably known
by 20 to 25 percent of the voting of the
voting power same about the santis would
you say no he's probably better known by
now because he's you know he's been
announced on his head then no no Newsome
is lesser known yeah Santa's is running
for president okay and and uh and you
know he's he's gotten a lot gotten a lot
of attention
um and also you know California is
perceived by most of the country as to
the left of of the rest of the country
and it is to the left of the rest of the
country and
you know it's
it's it to recognize the theater of
politics and you know who's willing to
sit with sit with
um
John Hannity and and who who's not but
they're also you know issues that there
are profound differences and one of the
things we learned in the midterms was
abortion is a voting issue in this no
question about it and if you if Joe
Biden goes to the public and says
if Donald Trump wins abortion is going
to be illegal in the whole country which
it really might be if the Congress
passes a law which a lot of members of
the Congress want want to do where and
if I'm elected president reelected
abortion is going to remain legal in the
states where it's illegal
where it's where it's still legal that's
that may be more important than anything
else because that is a substantive
difference that people can see have
implications in their real lives more
than the fact that
um you know he he's old
and and you may have a point there if
the economy stays intact if there's no
Ukraine Russia doesn't get uglier than
it already is today if China doesn't
anything anything else with Taiwan if
there's not that Cyber attack that
they're talking about could be coming in
the next 12 months if there's a lot of
ifs if yeah but if none of that happens
and it goes intact and he drives that
that's going to be a big issue what do
you think is going to be the second and
third issue that Democrats want to hear
well I I think
um the the the the look every
presidential election at some level is
about the state of the economy that's
that's certainly
um you know going to be Central and and
also you know peace peace in the world
it's the economy stupid yeah it's you
know it's it's the economy stupid I
think at the moment uh Biden Biden has a
good story to tell also you know his his
the the fact that he passed that big
infrastructure bill which the the
projects are going to start to come
online where people are actually going
to see the bridges that the highways the
mass transit start start to be fixed all
of that I think is is going to be a big
a big part of his pitch in addition to
abortion but as you point out you know
if the economy goes south that becomes
an enormous problem for him but at the
moment it hasn't yet and well that's
absolutely right about the if there's
always an if that's a notice yeah one
could argue if kovig didn't exist Donald
Trump would currently be the president
United States absolutely you agree with
that well I I I I mean certainly covet
played a big part in Biden in Biden's
Victory you know this sort of what if if
something else that happened it's very
hard to to know but you're certainly
right that kovid was was was a big issue
and and you know this also goes for
DeSantis too that you would have not
known whatsoever well and and and you
know I I don't know at the moment it
doesn't look like he's going to beat
Trump but if he beats Trump
um and becomes the nominee the way he
handled kovid will will be a big uh part
of the of the presidential campaign
although
presidential elections tend to be more
forward-looking than backward looking
and Jeffrey do you think that the
centers even has a chance considering
that the indictment just came out and
Trump went up he went up in the polls I
absolutely think the Santa's has a
chance oh wow yeah oh oh absolutely has
a chance certainly
um you know I I mean
being indicted
is a really bad thing yeah and
um you know his presence in the
courtroom in New York and and now here
in Florida is not going to be optional
it's not like the civil case you know
which he lost uh in New York where he
didn't go well he didn't testify you
know when you're indicted and and you
know as a former Federal prosecutor it
is worth you know remembering that
um upwards of 90 of the people who were
indicted in federal court wind up either
pleading guilty or being convicted so
yeah 90 90. yeah so ultimately you're
saying there's a 90 chance that he's
doing well you know I I Donald Trump's
case is so he's such an anomalous
defendant that I don't know if you can
precise you know just treat him like an
ordinary defendant but a lot of these
cases are pretty routine this is
obviously not a routine case but
especially compared to the New York case
which I think is not a particularly
strong case and not something that most
voters would see is disqualifying the
federal case is is I think very
different
um and and and also just the rules of of
federal procedure
are tougher on defendants than than the
the New York rules are
um now again Trump got a good uh got a
good piece of luck with judge Cannon who
who has been sympathetic to him in the
past but you know it's still I think you
know yes the the in the initial wave he
um
um uh you know he got he got a certain
boost in the polls or at least the the
polls didn't change much if he's sitting
in court day after day and the public
has to ask itself
what if he's convicted how does how does
it work to have a convicted felon the
president of the United States I mean
that I I don't think you know the PO you
know we we in the news media we spend a
lot of time talking about polls
but you know the polls change and and
um you know events change the polls so
the idea I don't think the the world has
fully absorbed the magnitude of what it
means to be indicted not federal court
because it doesn't disqualify but don't
you think Jeff just from seeing that
that one poll his real support is here
his real followers that's Rob like that
that's making them more energetic
because they're seeing that one side is
getting treated one way he's getting
treated the other way if you think about
it you know this for a fact Hillary did
the same if not the exact same type of
stuff Joe Biden has documents but
they're locked by his Corvette and we
just saw it with Hunter just yesterday
they gave him two misdemeanors and
something else when we all know we all
know everything that was on his laptop
proved one it's it's 100 provable that
him with his father they were peddling
money and they were getting bribes but
like so don't know let's be honest Jeff
you don't think it's gonna help him
people seeing like look at what they're
doing to him and what they're not doing
to the other side you said about five
things yeah each one of which could be
could be debated but but
um
you you are certainly right that his
true believers will be energized by that
that's not enough to win a presidential
election His True Believers are maybe 30
of the country that's a lot of people a
lot of people but that's not enough to
win uh the to to win the presidency and
what
you know what remains to be seen is
um how the the rest the rest of the
public uh you're absolutely right that
it's enough to win a primary potentially
but it's not enough to Pivot to the
general election I want to stay on the
Trump indictment uh as a former attorney
are you still uh I'm still an attorney
congratulations
um you've seen Trump's former Attorney
General Bill Barr give a scolding rebuke
to what Donald Trump is doing and he
defends him in many ways still right
yeah uh you know it basically says that
a lot of the Russia collusion stuff and
the impeachment stuff was a sham but on
this particular issue the FBI search
documents ever that he's basically
coming out and vocalizing Yeah Trump is
absolutely in the wrong here what's your
opinion on what Bill Barr is basically
saying about well I I think it's
significant because I I think but you
know we now live in such an incredibly
polarized political environment that any
time someone on your side
says you're wrong it becomes it becomes
very significant you know the fact that
Adam Schiff thinks Donald Trump did
something wrong who cares right I mean
exactly I mean that that that's to be
pretty that's to be that's man that's to
be
um to be expected but as you point out
yes Bill Barr was his attorney general
was a trump defender in many respects uh
and and top attorney in the United
States yeah and and you know the unlike
the New York case
the the Florida case is pretty easy to
understand I mean it's it's not it's not
a super complicated break it down like
we're all fifth grade well it's it's
that you know when you are President of
the United States you are allowed to
declassify anything you want and uh but
you have to actually do it
but if you take stuff with you
and they asked for it back
you have to give it back
and he seems actively to have known that
he had stuff that he wasn't supposed to
have and then in the face of a subpoena
said I'm not giving it back anyway
that's a crime that's a crime that other
people have been Pro other people have
been prosecuted just for possessing the
documents forget not giving them back
and you know it's not
um and this is where you know the
difference from the Hillary Clinton and
the in the in the Joe Biden situation
comes along they were never asked to
give back and they found the stuff and
gave it back voluntarily not Hillary
well no no Hillary destroyed and hold on
Hillary Clinton had all the blackberries
destroyed she had a server in her
basement in her house and as a United
States Air Force veteran who had top
secret clearance that was just all over
that was done way before any request was
no requests hold on what the FBI asked
for it they destroyed everything no they
destroyed it earlier before
but you're allowed to destroy anything I
mean in your private property you're
allowed to do anything you want that's a
little weird it's a little suspect
that's a little bit
Shady but not illegal it's not it's
there's no there's no that's not gonna
be a crime that shouldn't be so so for
example let's just say you have a cell
phone right yeah if tonight you want to
destroy your cell phone it's not a
government issue no no that's not a
government issued cell phone no those
are all black don't that was all of her
staff's blackberries they destroyed them
and then all their emails they did that
white what's it called Robin they took
all that white [__] where you can't ever
see a bleach bit that's what it's called
bleach bit come on Jeff if you can't
admit that there's a double standard
right now and the day that the
indictment comes out it was the same day
that we found out about the hunter
barisma everything the time but hunter
Biden was prosecuted by Trump's U.S
attorney in Delaware okay Merrick
Garland recused himself this was
entirely a decision by Trump's U.S
attorney what's the what how was that
Joe Biden protecting his son I mean that
was not he Joe Biden and Joe Biden's
attorney general had nothing to do with
it the whole issue was the whole
um prosecution was conducted by someone
appointed by Donald Trump right I think
that the issue here is Optics
Vinnie where'd you go to law school
again uh United States Air Force okay
gotcha so you're not a legal analyst but
he does have an opinion
I don't have a lawyer I mean I
know it's a lot of people who share
Vinnies opinion right they're not they
didn't they're not reading tort reform
or they're not going to law school but
I'm not they're just basically saying
something's [__] fishy here bro but
but sometimes it takes a legal analyst
to be like hold on this is how the law
works well and also you know Senator
Daniel Patrick Moynihan was was someone
I covered a lot someone I liked a lot he
had something that uh he said something
that that always sticks with me said
Everyone's entitled to their own opinion
but they're not entitled to their own
facts yeah and you know the the idea
that you know Joe Biden or Merrick
Garland you know gave Hunter Biden a a
sweet deal yeah it's just not a fact now
you can argue that that hi that by that
Hunter should have been more harshly
dealt with but you can argue that it was
somehow a Biden initiative that that he
did it I got a question for you I got a
question for you so let's just say
if I have 10 people that at one point in
my life were best friends
and prior to meeting me they had never
done cocaine before
these 10 people 10 out of 10 eventually
became cocaine addicts and killed
themselves
simply by association with me
I probably have some bad influence on
these people okay
this this this lady named Hillary
Clinton one too many of her best friends
or close friends have committed suicide
into random ways she is not the most
trusted person even by the left she was
supposed to be president you were not
alone we everybody thought that was a 3
30 in the morning I'm on a call with ma
with Tom
and he's saying what they were silenced
like on what's going on you know the
video with all the people losing their
minds crying all this stuff I mean the
New York at the convention yeah the
convention was already set up you know
she called all this stuff sure nobody
believed it but why because people
didn't trust her mess some of the stuff
that came up even with Comey said what
he said and that didn't help him help
her two weeks prior to that uh the the
level of double standard with how she
handled herself
that for sure is there there's no
questions about it when you say
something like well you can do whatever
you want to your phones and you can do
whatever you want to this I get that but
if the other guy would have said hey
accidentally these files burned there
was a fire in Mar-A-Lago oh it wasn't
you guys would have lost your mind if
you would have said there was an
accidental fire all I'm saying is I'm
talking only to Libertarians and
independents I'm not talking to
Republicans and I'm not not talking to
Democrats I'm not even talking to rhinos
I'm not talking to Lincoln project folks
who cannot stand Trump I'm not standing
to Bush folks I'm not standing to a a
McCain folks I'm not talking to those
people I'm talking to Independence and
Independence on Libertarians like a Joe
Rogan like a musk these are people that
were voting for the left these are
people that wanted to vote for Bernie
Sanders Joe Rogan wanted to vote for
Bernie Sanders is who he wanted to vote
for this is a guy that was for
legalizing marijuana totally okay with
LGB you know his friend you know totally
okay with this is like this there's
something really fishy here so the the
Hillary Clinton's never going to lose
your loyalty you know they're not you're
not going to say I'm gonna flip you're
not going to do that and the people who
on the mega side Trump's not going to
lose their loyalty it's just not going
to happen that's naturally there right
it's like a Yankees fan how often does a
Yankee fan who's been a Yankee fan since
six years old become a Red Sox fan at 60
years old just not going to happen right
so if you're going to convert religion
you do it early if you're going to
convert teams you're going to do it or
if you're going to cover you generally
do it early but the people in the middle
who are kind of like let me see what he
has to say and let me see what he has to
say come on bro what are you talking
about you're saying to me that Hillary
Clinton didn't I'm kind of with him here
I don't agree with you because I see
because you know you know the argument
that the left makes
and they say
Democrats want Trump as the candidate
that's who they want because he's the
guy that we will beat again
really
if that's who you want as a candidate
then don't do this stuff
well well no we we have to indict him
and we have to do New York and we have
to do this stuff because we just have to
do well I'm sorry you said he's the guy
that you're certain you're going to be
why don't you not do this because every
time you do his post go up well that's
strategically because we actually want
him to be DeSantis because we believe he
will lose to Biden and we believe that
Santa's will beat Biden we've heard all
that story many many times right so
there is some leaks in the argument
where the person who's sitting there
saying listen I'm not there to see all
the reports and I know Adam is defending
you as a lawyer saying listen Adam you
know who is Vinnie to say this you're a
lawyer you read all these things totally
get that but the average voter who has
this this technology that we all possess
especially the independent and
libertarian ones is a [__] a modder
whatever you want to call it where
you're kind of sitting there saying I
smell a little bullshitting here from
one side over the other I think that
party is also sick of it to the point
where you know musk and Rogan to say you
want to save America vote Republican
if there was two people that you
wouldn't have ever thought to say those
two things it was going to be those two
guys and they changed in their 50s Not
in their 30s or their 20s that's the
community that's sitting there saying
they don't trust anything from Biden or
Hillary Clinton that happens to your son
they don't trust anything I'm sort of
amazed that that we are you know we are
talking about the 2024 presidential
election and and people you're talking
so much about Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton has been out of public life for
eight years I mean what did Hillary and
Biden in the same camp well all right
but and anyway I mean Biden is certainly
you know appropriate to talk about yeah
and and you know musk and Rogan I you
know only brought up Hillary because you
brought up Hillary you brought up
Hillary earlier well actually I think I
brought up in response to what he said
but that's fine you know whatever no no
you brought up Hillary when you said
when I got it wrong
that's what I'm saying I was wrong and
and I as I certainly was wrong in 2016.
I I I think presidential campaigns this
is something Bill Clinton often said and
I think he was right is that
presidential campaigns are always about
about the future and you know how you
envision
um the the things going forward and
um you know I what what I can never get
my hands head around is that we we often
view these campaigns as you know a form
of theater and who's more likable who's
more trustworthy it's like these have
real world consequences and and that's
why I think abortion is such a big issue
because it's not about like who's who's
more likable it's like a big difference
in people's lives depending on the
outcome of the election
and same thing about climate change I
mean you have people you know have one
political party that thinks it's not a
particular problem you have another
political party that thinks you know the
the government has to mobilize uh
against it
that to me and and you know maybe that's
just a flaw in how I see politics but I
see it as more substantive than the the
the theater aspect but I recognize and a
lot of people and this is my thing Jeff
and I and I respect your opinion but my
thing is when people say stuff like
that's back then it was Hillary it was
eight years ago people like me come up
and they say I just want accountability
I want I don't give a damn if it
happened 30 58 10 JFK assassination
we're finding out the CIA was involved I
want people to be held accountable
because for instance you see the Russia
the Russia thing we just found out that
was literally Hillary Clinton set it all
up paid you know Fusion GPS they all
they all set them up now the public is
like wait a minute can we hold her
accountable you we have to be dragged
through CNN which was the biggest
mouthpiece for that big ass lie for all
those years now we find out Hillary was
behind it that was the real collusion
hold on Jeff and no accountability they
didn't do what the DNC got fined like
eight thousand dollars for dragging us
through that nonsense for all those
years we want accountability and when
you destroy phones Jeff it's not her
cell phone when your whole staff is
government-owned cell phones and you're
destroying evidence and then hold on and
that we talked about attorney general
Loretta Lynch with James Comey they're
about to she would have been uh her
charge would have been gross negligence
which is called which is you could go to
jail correct for gross negligence while
of a sudden last minute they changed it
to extreme carelessness one side has it
way better than the other side and when
you have the FBI kind of leaning towards
the left which we've learned Jeff we
can't you can't lie with Peter strzok
and and uh Lisa Page and the whole FBI
and we keep finding out stuff with the
Twitter files they lean way more left
than they do right I just want somebody
to get be held accountable for what they
did that's just my point that's it I I I
I I respect your point and I I think you
you know you you are very concerned
about accountability I think
presidential elections are going to much
more about the future than about who's
accountable so forget about the so
forget about the fact by the way no
these not forget about it but it's just
not
I I don't think it's relevant to the
who's who you're going to vote for in
2024 how you felt about Hillary
Clinton's you know Jeffrey on my emails
I'm going to interject here for a second
because
I think that's being a little dismissive
um you know how you said facts don't
care about you know your feelings
opinions what Vinnie's trying to convey
he's basically a mouthpiece of millions
of people who feel that way
whether he's right or wrong good luck
convincing somebody not to feel away so
what I think and I'm not saying that I'm
coming at you like you're the tip of the
spirit for the DNC or anything like that
yeah but use Vinnie
as a metaphor for freaking Millions tens
of millions of America who feel that way
who's basically saying what the [__] is
going on here it seems like there's two
completely different Justice systems and
dude I'm as moderate as it comes I'll go
left I'll go right I'm down to party but
there's so many people on the right oh
by the way just this is coming from a
guy that has never voted for a
Republican president ever ever so he's
saying that so what I would say is the
following here's what I would say would
what he said by the way the climate
change thing that you said that people
are worried about climate change uh
Greta thundberg five years ago today
today it's June 21st she said that
because if we don't stop fossil fuels
today was the Doomsday today make it
through today
climate change scientists is warning
that climate change will so we could die
today's wipes out of all of humanity
unless we stop fossil fuels over the
next five years okay
so this is what happens when you listen
to a 13 year old she was 15. but by the
way but by the way this is not about
what happens when you listen to 15 year
old you chose to put this person as a
spokesperson and use him as a person of
influence to get younger people and she
was very influential trust me this
girl's got more influence than most
people even believe she does
by the way but she's not I mean I look
is what she's saying is not that that it
will that on five five years from now
Humanity will cease to exist it's it's
that eventually and if you look at
um you know the the the melting of the
polar ice caps the melting of Greenland
the melting uh the the rising of the
Seas that's not an unreasonable
prediction
that's not unreasonable prediction at
all do you really believe that that that
climate change is going to affect I
think kind of it obviously I mean you
don't think climate change is going to
affect I mean here we are sitting in
South Florida you don't think the rising
season is going to affect Miami climate
change is uh okay so do you want to have
the climate change debate let's finish
this and we can catch up man you know I
don't want to get into something no no
no no no but no but but what you brought
it up so yeah we can talk about as none
of us being Specialists nobody here so
whoever gets it we can all get it wrong
right but let me go back to the point
about the future thing okay
uh I agree with them partly let me
explain to you why you remember how the
whole thing is like they stole the
election they stole the election they
stole the election you know who's the
first person that said that Hillary
Clinton 100 they stole it like Russia
could raise the whole election but
nobody said anything the more she went
and the more she did that the more she
looked like a victim I could I couldn't
stand it when you're a sore loser and
you lose and you can do it you know who
did it next
trumped it 100 okay and guess what
you're living what they stole the
election they stole the election
whether they did or not either side
voters want you to say we lost let's
move on okay left right middle it
doesn't matter let's move on however hey
for those that believe there may have
been meddling in the election Etc et
cetera here's what we have to do the
solution is don't vote by yourself go
with twos go with threes go with four
give me the solution because that's now
moving forward right here's where we
want to go so that part I agree with
them is future Obama sold the campaign
in 2008 yeah you know you know Clinton
show sold future Kennedy sold future
Reagan sold future right yeah and even
Trump sold future in 2016 when he won
America let's make America great again
now let's make this it's the Future Okay
um Trump's campaign started sloppy
because he wasn't selling the future he
was selling the past all right
having said that
um there is a part of me that uh uh uh
you know I want to know like for example
this whole thing about who cares where
Kobe came from I'm sorry what I want to
know where covet came from do you care
who cares like I remember one time
Hillary Clinton was asking who cares
they're dead they're no longer oh yeah
why does it matter what does it matter
about Benghazi what oh my God what do
you mean who cares that's the camp left
or right that's the Ken that says who
cares we're already past this no listen
kovid ruined a lot of people's lives the
the the the the the leading surgeon what
do you call it the Surgeon General came
out and said hey here's what we learned
about covet is that these shutdowns led
to people needing to be around each
other and why it's so important to be
around each other wait a minute you just
realize the zoom concept didn't work
working remotely that we need to be
around each other because we need each
other's company we're just starting to
realize that now we're just starting to
realize how this affected kids no no no
we can't say who cares we have to go
back and find out what happened to
prevent it from happening again and if
China did it they have to be held
accountable and now we know the first
three cases were the doctors that were
out of China one that came out that's
not even something that's being debated
about it's public information that
they're talking about now we have to
find that out okay and we have to find
out whether fauci was involved with
different cases you know was he uh you
know gain function he was were they
doing that were they not doing I was
involved with us who was funding it
where did the money come from people
want to know there's a reason why like
think about messages that go viral for
example
what did we learn midterms Republicans
screwed up royally not a little bit
royally they screwed up with abortion
you're 100 right no one's disagreeing
with that but watch this here
who's RFK
Robert F Kennedy
he lost his father and he lost his uncle
two people that were loved and admired
probably by both sides establishment
didn't like those guys The Establishment
couldn't stand the Kennedy family at all
because they were going up against the
establishment they couldn't stand those
guys
so all right can you go on Amazon and
type in Robert Kennedy Jr if he can just
go on Robert Kennedy Jr I think he did
nobody wanted to publish this book
through anybody go to the Anthony fauci
one I read that was a great book okay so
zoom in a little bit
uh it's number four this week this thing
was written two years ago it's got 23
000 reviews over a million copies sold
and who published it go to the bottom uh
go to the bottom go to the bottom go to
the bottom let's see who published it go
to about keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going
um uh oh my God okay okay
Sky horse publishing yeah who was Sky
horse publishing go Google who Sky
horses they publish a lot of books that
other Publishers want oh my God so it's
kind of like a true yeah okay perfect so
Sky horse publishing takes some of the
guys that people don't want to publish
so then the question becomes why did the
book do so well why did it sell so many
copies maybe because people want to know
why did Roe v Wade create such a big
maybe because that's an important thing
to women including left and the right so
guess what Republicans you have to
respect that and pay attention to it
guess what Democrats you have to find
out what the hell happened with this
Anthony fauci guy so to me the only
thing that the only point I'm making
I'll kind of turn it back over to you
and we can go to the next subject the
only thing I'm saying is the Future Part
I'm with it I agree you have to sell the
dream of the future where we're going
but the accountability part if there's
not really any Law and Order then this
whole thing about a guy like O.J Simpson
who got away which by the way oh you're
not liked by O.J Simpson no I'm aware of
that but by the way
you know what that says that's a
compliment well you know my dad always
used to say you can you can you can tell
someone you you can tell a lot about
someone by their enemies and you know
the fact that O.J Simpson is my enemy
but what I'm saying to you is I respect
the fact that he doesn't like you
because we wanted to know what happened
so there's a part of the accountability
part that there's a lot of people that
are saying I just want to get to the
bottom of us see who was behind me well
and and this is the thing you know this
the the covet thing you know interests
me for for a specific reason I mean
there is a active scientific debate
about the the ultimate source of covet
did it come from a lab did it come from
an animal uh you know an animal and I
um
I'm just a guy who went to law school I
know [__] all about it about
epidemiology
I you know how could you possibly ask
someone like me what the source of covid
was oh that's not what I'm asking no but
but in general but I'm saying but what
else we should yeah we should ask Vinnie
yeah but but but shut up that is a
question that should be addressed in
good faith by people who have some idea
about how to determine that I don't know
the source of covid yeah but no but I
mean that's that to me but but but but
that these questions that become
politicized it seems ridiculous to me to
have political debates about something
that is a scientific question that
people should address and I'm agreeing
that there should be investigations of
all that by the way Brett Bear did you
see the interview with Trump yes I saw
okay excerpts did you see did you think
he did a good job uh no or even Brett
Bear yeah I thought Brett Baird did a
very good I agree I think and you know
how he said this person say this person
got fired that person got fired this
person got fired why do you not have a
good you know so he asked a tough
question and hey you know why is it that
you're keeping on to it they were trying
to get it from you well I wanted to
First make sure okay so guess what
people want to know great but people
want to also know what the core red
backing with the notes we know what you
had there's a bite people want to know
as well people want to know and there is
an investigation going on absolutely all
I'm saying to you is people want to know
that we want to know what's behind the
truth the the the the comment about the
fact that I'm not an appeal you know I'm
not I'm not this I'm not that I'm
totally get it the element of that
approach when you say something like
well you're not the expert in this and
you're not the expert in that there is a
there is a very clear pompous elitist
message behind that like just like this
week when MSNBC and CNN well we know the
president is talking right now Jake
Tapper and Rachel maddabo you know we
know what the president is talking about
we listen we are not going to let him
have any air time and we're going to
update you on whatever he says that's
necessary because we know he's going to
tell lies I'm sorry do you think I'm a
[__]
do you think I don't have a mind for my
like I can't make what the hell is
America all about you just said I'm a
[__] that's what you you just said to
half of America hey America you're a
[__] you can't think for yourself
that's why you need me because I went to
this elitist university called whatever
whatever Colombia I don't know where
Rachel went to and I know what's best
for you guess what I don't like that
that's why I left Iran there's a reason
why we don't live in Iran for 10 10
years old when I lived in New Orleans we
went to Germany at a refugee camp for
two years then we came to America
because I want me to make the stupid
decision on who I vote for not you let
me make this stupid decision of voting
for Biden or Trump there's a part of
that where when we say I'm not the
expert you're not this you're well no
you're a smart guy that's why you're
here you're not a regular schlep off the
street that doesn't know what you've
been involved in a lot of different
things I investigated all I'm saying is
for us to take the approach as well to
say Hey you know you don't know what
you're talking about you don't have this
you don't know what you're talking about
no we're here because we don't know
everything but we're here to question
things and say this cat sounds a little
fishy don't you want to know about it I
do well no let's just live in the future
forget about the past no no I don't want
to do that I completely agree that you
know everybody that you know you we
don't we don't have
um you know tests to to determine
whether you know you're entitled to an
expression opinion on a subject well the
only point I was making was uh there are
certain scientific questions like the
source of covid that it it really does
require
some considerable expertise in the
subject in order to have a reasonable
opinion about it that that's the only
point I was making and I don't I I'm not
saying that you know I mean what is what
is more than legitimate is you or Vinnie
or anybody saying we need an
investigation of of the source of covet
that everybody you know that's a
perfectly legit 100 right but but the
ultimate question of what the source of
covet is I want to rely on people who
know something and who's leading that
investigation yeah exactly who is I
don't know that's my fault where's this
investigation and and I go investigate
laptops and leaks and this and that no
no but something that shut down the
world for two and a half years but no
investigation what is that Adam China
runs bro if China could fly spy balloons
over our entire country over nuke bases
and nothing happens nobody's
investigating [__] but here's my thing
which is absurd here's my thing Jeff and
you know I'm not an expert you nobody in
here knows [__] about epidemiology right
right but guess what it doesn't help
when the experts were trying to talk and
the government was silencing them when
Peter McCullough was trying to talk when
Robert Malone was time to talk they
banned them on YouTube they took them
off Twitter how do we even have a chance
how am I supposed to learn from the
experts when they were shut down and now
it's years later and now we're like oh
it's old news no no again accountability
and that's why I Pat the thing with um
with Joe Rogan he wants to have that
debate with the bringer bring a
scientist
I am fine so let me think about that
yeah what do you think about it I mean I
I I actually am sympathetic you know if
if you want to have a scientific debate
have two scientists debate it not Joe
Rogan against some sign he doesn't want
to do that either but Hotes doesn't even
want to debate two expert signed that
are on the opposing side it's I
understand the argument you're saying
like why should we debate RFK is not
fine okay that's a reasonable argument
but why don't you get a couple other
experts I
having people who know something about
it should debate but but you know I
shouldn't debate no of course well
Jeffrey why do you know anything about
it yeah America wants to see this debate
conversation dialogue for sure whether
it's uh RFK or Malone or McCulloch and
then versus a fauci or Dr hote fill in
the blank in your non-expert legal
opinion why do you think this debate has
not happened why has it not occurred yet
here in America well it is happening I
mean I mean look look we're having this
conversation no no but none of us are
experts I'm talking ex there are there
are scientific papers being published
all the time
yeah how many scientific papers have you
read I haven't read it but I mean
nobody's reading that but people want to
visualize and see they're saying just
like that there's debating with a camera
on is that kind of what you're saying I
mean yeah like a debate I mean not
scientific paper
you will
there there will be given the level of
interest in it there will be plenty more
discussion on this subject among people
who know what they're talking about and
that's a good thing I hope and by the
way I hope so because what one of the
things like when you run a company and
you know there's those that are
complainers and you can't give too much
credit to complainers because they're
everywhere so these are the people that
complain about everything if a person
complains about every single issue they
have this much credibility right but if
a person who doesn't complain once a
year they say Pat can I just bring
something up I don't like the way we do
this here you know what I do I pay
attention to what they have to say Okay
so let's set aside the complainers that
just complain about everything in life
what do we learn about people in America
hey this abortion thing listen it's
legit kind of pay attention to it it's
very important to us check get it
respect
uh hey this uh this thing with uh uh
covet that ruined our lives as a mother
I had to stay home and had to do this
and had to cost my job and I didn't want
to take the vaccine but I did take it
and I had to do this and I I didn't like
that part can you guys please not do
this again and give me a different
option the next time around you know
what this is not a complainer this is a
positive citizen they go to work they
raise their kids they pay their taxes
check let's pay attention to this all
I'm saying is let's pay attention to the
people that are saying those things
let's investigate that and give them a
opportunity to see the opposing side
especially because
there are going to be more pandemics
there are going to be more communicable
diseases exactly I agree and
um we need
um to to know what works and what
doesn't and
um I I just I I think you know planning
for future pandemics is what responsible
government should crazy question for you
crazy question for you to see what you
think about this
so um
1984 I think it is uh that we make
advertising uh can you look up when we
made advertising big Pharma legal in
America I think it's 84. and I think
Prozac came out in 88 87 if you can look
up when Prozac came out and when we made
it legal what year is it when we made it
legal is it uh search that zoom in
you'll see it okay anyways while you're
doing that what do you think would
happen if
out of a couple hundred countries in the
world whatever the numbers 193 or 208
okay only two countries big Pharma gets
to advertise in those countries New
Zealand and America okay
what do you think about if a president
campaigned and said moving forward guess
what if your product is good they'll
find it no more advertising on media tv
YouTube social big Pharma not necessary
because it's a legalized drug dealers if
you're if your work is great if it's
doing phenomenal great I feel a little
bit uncomfortable that this person I'm
paying 15 million dollars a year 10
million dollars a year this much money
per year of course they're going to say
good things about the drug because I'm
getting the money let's not do that
moving forward what do you think about
us eliminating as a candidate would you
somebody who is on the you know maybe on
the left supportive or more on the
Democratic side would you say I actually
would entertain the idea of getting rid
of that well and and there's another
very good argument for getting rid of
drug advertising which is you know one
of the big issues 85 with with
um
with drugs at this you know
Pharmaceuticals at this point is how
much they cost I mean you know the fact
that people can't afford the medication
they need
in a world where there's advertising why
are we through Medicare or Medicaid or
through our insurance paying these drug
companies to advertise I mean that it's
not it's not that it's not that we're
learning it's not just that
um we may be getting in you know getting
unnecessary prescriptions it's that
you're adding to the cost just by um the
the in the the cost of advertising it's
it's a it's a very legitimate question
you know one of the things that uh and I
can I I uh I certainly knew this from my
time at CNN you know in an age when a
lot of formerly uh big advertisers don't
advertise anymore like for example I I
I'm going to take the liberty of saying
that all of you are old enough to
remember when Airlines used to advertise
on TV all the time oh big time they
don't advertise at all anymore you never
see a Delta add a United had
um
if you turn on CNN if you turn on MSNBC
if you turn on Fox it's one Pharmacy
it's not just left or right it's
everybody well and also this has to do
with the fact that the news audience is
older exactly and I used to I used to
joke I mean this is sort of a dark joke
I love it about uh when I was at CNN
that you know that you know if you look
at the ads that I our audience
is a hundred percent done uh because of
what they need like there was one ad
that was used to run all the time it's
like
you take this drug if you have advanced
lung cancer oh my God it's like can't we
have a drug for people who have just a
little bit of lung cancer yeah wherever
it's like why do I have to have like
Advanced lung cancer but that's that's
who that you know that's the audience
and and you know people Fox you know fox
has the biggest audience they also have
the oldest audience and
um you know the and but but across the
board the ads are for
um
um you know of pharmaceuticals because
that's I want to show something Rob I'm
going to show this to you because the
point you're making right now so do you
know the patent laws and Drugs in
America do you know the patent law so so
the patent laws in America uh
pharmaceutical companies get 12 years
guaranteed Market Market exclusivity for
biologists and 20 years for each patent
okay so you know it used to be 12 they
raise it to 20.
the a senator and a congressman from the
left and the right agreed to say let's
lower to 12. this is not cool and then
eventually they brought it back up I'm
going to send you these two things so
two of the most popular drugs that we
take in America one of them is
um listen excuse my English being my
fifth language Lipitor am I saying
Liberator okay all right so Lipitor Rob
I'm gonna send this to your map I take
it myself
Rob if you can receive it and pull it up
when you see this on what happens the
year the patterns go away okay so check
this out if you can show this uh uh uh
Rob did you get it or no okay I would I
would run on this and I would show this
because this whole concept of
advertising Pharma and US losing these
people because they're getting paid
behind closed doors there's loyalty to
whoever helps pay your bills there's a
loyalty to whoever's The Advertiser for
the most time watch this for the most
part
Rob do you have them
okay so okay there you go so if you see
the drop-off of these two numbers the
year the patent is over with so it's
showing what it's selling for and how
much the patent expires if if I but if
before we even look at the zoom in a
little bit can you zoom in a little bit
generic yeah yeah so this is Lipitor
okay zoom in and go up a little bit the
other way so we can see the bottom
numbers okay so check this out look at
that how high it is okay uh it's going
uh one and a half billion to see the
chart yep so all the way at the top look
what kind of numbers they're doing 12
billion is the top 12 billion 2012 is
when the patent expires look how low it
goes from doing 12 billion at its peak
to 76 million dollars go to the next one
this is Lipitor now let's do the next
one here which is for
a drug for bipolar and uh so look at
this one here five point six to eight
billion Peak 2011. it expires look how
quickly it drops and look how much it's
worth in 2021.
92 million versus 5.2 billion in
revenues from One Drug okay so this is
the part where Americans are like dude
so really it didn't really cost you this
much to make it no bro it's like Pennies
on a dollar but we charge you 600 bucks
damn there's a part of this where I'm
like look you know I don't mind giving
you a a a patent you ought to get it
because we want innovation in in this
space no questionable like listen cancer
we got a cure and there's respect to a
lot of advancement that we have made we
have to salute 100 my dad's 81 years old
he should have been there not 65 years
old Ken golden who is one of the
original guys from uh
from uh Home Depot billionaire 45
Billion Auto guy
he had a phenomenal debate with
Elizabeth Warren two three years ago he
said my dad died at 62 years old he's
saying this in his book I love
capitalism he said but if my dad would
have been born 20 years later when they
invented blood thinners my dad would
have lived in his 80s he says because
I've been on blood thinner since I was
60 years old and he's now 83 84 years
old so what an interesting testimony so
we want the Innovation but guess what 20
years patent I don't know about that how
about we lower it to five years and then
five years later the person that came up
with the patent you get to sell it to
other people and whatever they sell 50
comes to you which means you release the
patent that there's still some kind of
profits coming back to you I think this
is another thing that's going to force
big Pharma to be more honest if we
eliminate advertising and if we minimize
the patent from 20 years to five years
it becomes a little bit more competitive
you make a great great point we have
Medicare and Social Security which is a
safety net originally designed as a
safety net to help the elderly so there
is a very real spreadsheet that goes on
in Medicare to getting life-saving drugs
life-extending drugs to these people and
it is kind of funked up that the drug
companies have less of a copyright or
patent than Mickey Mouse a couple years
ago you read about how hard Disney was
working to protect the image of Mickey
Mouse because of its commercial value
and the branding value to Disney so why
does why do we have those things which
argue that hey it was built by a company
it's entertained by people you can do it
but it's not necessarily as critical as
other drugs are and I think I think what
you're bringing up Pat is instead of
opening the floodgates to the generics
because they always talk about the
Canadian generics when you if you go
deep into the Medicare discussion you go
straight to the Canadian Church yeah 24
months 24 months after the expiration
hey why can't we buy the Canadian
generics for our older people to say hey
you can still get your Lipitor but
you'll just get the Canadian generics
it's a lot less because the patent's up
now we can get over here
why not make the licensing option of it
take away the advertising and provide a
longer term licensing option at the same
time finding ways to you know make the
the drugs themselves more affordable
because we can all scream about the
costs and everything but there's a
couple realities the competitive set
United States is resulting in these
drugs these drugs are not being invented
around the world and this is the reason
that John Hopkins you've got and you
know about this you're familiar with
Washington you've got entire floors that
John Hopkins have special security
because foreign dignitaries are coming
here for Advanced Health Care Services
why is that because the competitive set
of capitalism and things in Free
Enterprise in America are resulting in
in competing to make medical instruments
and stuff so the right thing is happens
that competition is resulting in great
things but then long term we need to get
the cost under control and you take away
the advertising and Pat you're right you
put licensing on it and you will take
five steps in a direction I have a
question for you Jeffrey it's kind of
moving away from the drug stuff so I
don't ever want to stay there but it is
regarding what we're talking about and
that is of course CNN you worked there
for how long 20 years 20 years so when
you were hired who was the CEO wow there
were there was a lot of turnover at the
beginning it was Walter Isaacson was the
CEO who who hired me Walter um
chapter of his career he was the editor
of Time Magazine and at that point my
magazine was owned by Time Warner which
was part of a part of part of the Time
Warner company and briefly
um he took over CNN and he hired me he
used to joke that was the only good
thing he did while he was in CNN I don't
know I hope he still feels that way but
you know Walter laughed uh CNN and then
and and started writing all these
terrific when did you work at Sienna
what year was it when did I start it
well I was at ABC from 96 to 2002 and
then CNN 2002 to 2012. Ted Turner was
still around at that time or no well I
mean Ted Turner is still around no no
but but I mean it's he was not over the
company no no he was he was not how
different is CNN then than it is today
considerably different
um the
um the when I started it was still in
the era of the the the line that and
this is a Ted Turner line was the news
is the star
that
um it was not about the the
personalities other than Larry King who
was nine to ten the anchors were not
particularly well known not and and it
was very much like a sort of wire
service like the AP or um and
um it
and and that is a dramatic
transformation from where it was now the
the key point about 2002 is that the
internet was still in its infancy so
if you wanted news
you really had to go to to CNN
as the internet became ubiquitous
people would get the news first on their
screens than on their phones and by the
time you turned on your TV you already
knew the headlines and that's when CNN
really started to change a lot and you
were there up until 2022 I want to say
yeah so uh going back to my initial
question regarding the CEOs you were
there Jeff Zucker was there for a decade
plus yes and then recently Chris Licht
was hired then fired yeah I don't know
if there's a new CEO right now if they
haven't hired okay gotcha so you said
that things have changed significantly
yeah you said you know the news was the
star right we've seen recently the stars
have actually been fired Don Lemon Cuomo
right yeah Anderson Cooper's still there
wolf Blitz are still there uh you made a
little joke about the average age of the
audience is dying or actually dead yeah
same thing that's approximate yeah of
course you know give or take a few years
Grandma's watching I love you stay
strong
um you know the whole narrative about
mainstream media is that it's a dying uh
Legacy Media is dying and that the
average age of people is uh is dead the
other narrative is that they've lost
their credibility
um and that goes across the board uh you
know if you talk people on the left fox
has no credibility whatsoever zero why
we could even trust that the most
trusted name in news what have you and
then you go to CNN it's like anyone on
the right is like it's fake news it's
fake news we've all we've all we have
all this narrative uh speaking as
someone that's worked for CNN uh for 20
years how can CNN regain their
credibility it's a really tough question
and and
um and I think
um some some of the problems that we're
talking about are are more structural
than
um
than about any individual I mean you
know CNN makes most of its money not all
of it but makes most of its money from
um Carriage fees from the cable
companies what does that mean that means
like when if you if you get cable new if
you if you have a a cable TV at home you
pay a certain amount per month that's
why I cut the cord baby well this is the
thing and and you know let's say you pay
fifty dollars a month you know a dollar
goes to CNN two dollars goes to ESPN but
those that business is is dying now
there's a debate about how quickly it's
dying but no one really debates about
whether it's dying ESPN and so the
question is how does CNN and this is
true for see you know for for both MSNBC
and fox it's also true for ESPN which is
a bigger business than either one of
them
um how do they make the transition when
people get their news from the internet
rather than from cable
um what you know what what Zucker
recognized was that
um
when when
you know particularly at prime time
um every by the time they turned on
everybody already knew the headlines
they wanted analysis and they wanted
from people who were ideologically
simpatico
um and and so the the network I think
was what was accurate I don't think I
mean I I don't think anybody was lying
on CNN but it was certainly more
ideologically combative with Trump
um Chris lick tried to move away from
that but there isn't one of the things I
think we're learning is that you know
people go to news organizations now that
are ideologically sympathetical
not to learn anything new although one
of the things that you know people never
talk about here and it's interesting it
certainly hasn't come up in this
conversation is the network news and
here I do a quick I do a quiz my wife my
wife gets sick of this I want to ask the
four of you okay we love quizzes who are
the three Network news anchors now so
you got the Cronkite
on CBS ABC NBC who are okay let me give
it a shot okay on ABC you got David Dave
Muir correct uh on NBC you've got Lester
Holt very good
and then who the hell watches CBS
you got uh Stephen Colbert no no but I'm
kind of what I honestly don't even
really know
there no those names aren't sorry did I
get two out of three right you got two
out of three Nora O'Donnell is the crew
yeah but but you know it 20 years ago
Dan Rather Peter Jennings and Tom Brokaw
were three of the most famous people in
the United States I mean forget like and
there's credibility well that but a
number one mattered and it was a war it
was it was a war and and these and
and and those network shows still draw a
significant number of people every night
but they are not part of the political
conversation the way the the way cable
is and
um
you know the the the the the the and
they are not particularly ideological
those three shows but the question you
know that that I don't have the answer
to is sort of how the market evolves
when Court cutting continues yeah so
back to my uh yeah other question The
credibility thing so you know not all uh
Talking Heads Are are created the same
so for instance I find that Jake Tapper
has a lot of credibility I actually find
him to be a real journalist I mean some
people might disagree and then you have
some people like Don Lemon what it was
so freaking clear drama queen that he
was biased yeah who do you think is
actually the most Fair journalist these
days you know you got Tucker Carlson up
there that he's got a loyal audience
he's on Twitter now but people on the
left think he's an absolute full of [__]
and then you've got you know Rachel
Maddow that people love her on the left
people on the right think she's full of
[__] who do you find to be credible
these days well I I mean I love my
colleagues at CNN I think Jake Tapp for
Wolf Blitzer Anderson Cooper Aaron
Burnett
um our terrific journalists and I think
do a great job and I was very proud to
to work to work with them
um
uh so I mean they're they're what about
on the right you think Brett Bears up
there I think yeah the problem with Fox
I mean let's go for it well no but I
mean this is the thing that I really
um that that was was of great interest
and concern to me was the vaccine talk
that you know Tucker Carlson was and I
you know we could have a debate about
you know the sources of covid but
actively discouraging people from
getting vaccines was a monstrous killing
act on the part of Tucker Carlson and I
think that was appalling and a disgrace
and if you look at you know the death
rates of people
um you know the the the people who
didn't get vaccinated
um and and many of them in red States in
places where you know the the
conservative message was out there I
think that was a shameful shameful thing
that Tucker cross did I don't care if
you talks about Hunter Biden I don't
care if he talks about you know you know
pot the the you know Democrats are
terrible fine that's that's like
opinions and everybody's entitled to
that but but the the the vaccine talk
was a shameful shameful thing and in
Rupert Murdoch should be ashamed that he
allowed that to go on how closely were
you following the the Dominion lawsuit
very close okay yeah how much of that uh
do you have a blood piece coming out
about it in the New Yorker I'd love to
hear that yeah how much of that do you
think led to the beheading of Tucker
Carlson well that that's something that
is a great question and I don't know the
answer to that and and all the stuff
I've seen in the Press about Tucker
about Tucker's firing
has not been persuasive to me you know
the New York Times had this big story
that there was something he said in an
email about someone I forgot exactly
what it was it was then Scott Suzanne
Scott it was some like and it was like I
I cannot believe that that was the the
the basis for for fire reporters yelling
at their news director has been
happening since before now forever and
and and
the departure of Tucker from from Fox as
far as I can tell at least so far has
had really bad business implications for
them I mean they have not tried to hold
out Brett Bear pretty hard on that well
and and and and
um they I I you know we'll see when they
appoint a new anchor to that spot
um you know one of the interesting
things that has happened historically is
that when
um
you know his his influence diminished
when O'Reilly left his influence
diminished when Megan Kelly left her
influence diminished Katie lyric
um Katie well I'm just talking about the
fox people yeah yeah but I mean it's
true about Katie as well I'm applying it
across networks well yeah and and you
know for all that these networks are
declining
they are still the pathway to influence
except for Tucker though
60 million 50 million 30 million 70
million uh well yes for the first couple
times let's see so there's two things I
want to push back I wanted to hear you
out and I wanted you and Adam to go
around questioning but I'm going to jump
in here for a couple things so
um
as a seal of a company uh you know I at
first when you're a salesperson I went
from an employee to sales person to
sales leader to business owner and I had
no clue what it was to be a CEO trying
to be a CEO you're gonna have people
from all walks of life those that want
this those that are married those that
are single those that are Widow those
that are divorced those that are white
black we're 54 Latino we're 24
African-American we're 51 women so I
have people from all walks of life
different states we're in 49 states all
this stuff right and you have to kind of
pay attention to what people are saying
when covet happened we had a camp that
got the vaccine we had a camp that
didn't get the vaccine we had a camp
that was undecided of wanted to get the
vaccine and it was interesting because
it was getting political at one point
because the guys that didn't take the
vaccine who were not going to take the
vaccine looked at the vaccine people in
a interesting way of why would you take
the vaccine why would you put that in
your body you don't even know what's its
own nine months trial all this stuff and
the people that took the vaccine would
say why would you be so irresponsible
and not take the vaccine and then you
have the people in the middle that's
look I'm kind of undecided I don't know
what I'm going to do we may we may not
we're still waiting for three more
months great so when you say about the
this service Fox did Murdoch and Tucker
brother one on the other side could say
dude I was ousted you coerced judged
demonized for you know everybody was
forcing it down my throat with videos
and commercials and ads and people
getting up there and saying if you don't
do this you have to be fired and if they
don't do this you don't bring them and
see the other patient if you don't let
them go in the hospital the military
doesn't wait a minute what are you
talking about man I just don't know if I
want to take it yet or not so I think
when I when I ask and I see a trend like
you know the red pill movement did very
well for like a year and a half these
are men that are like dude I feel like I
don't have any girls out there for me
there's no dates all the guys are
getting the hot girls and I don't have
anything left for me no one's interested
in me I'm alone dude I need a girl I
want to date somebody this whole dating
Gap ruined my life at least back in the
days if I'm in a little city Toledo and
I like Karen and she was only competing
with 17 other guys it was me versus 17
and I'm number three out of the 17 guys
in my city I a chance with Karen today
Karen got one Instagram but can she get
16 000 DMS there's no way I can compete
with Karen they're willing to fly around
to go to New York or them so the
competition for the guys they took ahead
once the dating sites came out
it's probably going to be a name that we
will not see foreign
becomes that community in the middle
when you see why these Trends are doing
well there's a community that's like
look you try to force down the vaccine
on me man I didn't like that I don't
like what you did there as well so when
you say I don't like what fox did
There's tens of millions of people that
can say I can't stand what mainstream
media did to judge me just because I
wasn't ready to take the vaccine you
made me feel like [__] to want to take
the vaccine you made me feel like I'm a
[__] because I'm not willing to take it
that part is a little bit double
standard it's not it's not a and I'm
sorry I'm I'm I'm a complete hardliner
on this I I tell me what you mean
because is that you know in in in at CNN
and and at Fox you were not allowed in
the building unless you were vaccinated
you think that's the right thing to do I
thought it was exactly the right tell me
why because it's a communicable disease
that could that you could reduce the
your risk to yourself and to the people
around you
um to a scientific certainty and that
that was a rule that was excellent and I
was glad CNN had that role I'm sure the
people at Fox were glad they had that
had that role and
um you know again this is not you know
you're allowed to have opinions about
anything you want but at some point when
your opinions put other people at
physical risk as you know vaccine denial
did that that crossed the line you know
how ridiculous that is what you just
said because for for you to say that I
can I can hear someone saying that in
Iran
I can hear somebody saying that in in
North Korea I can hear someone saying
that in China I can see someone saying
that even in Italy although things are
changing in Italy right now with their
new leader that they have I can see
somebody saying that in Venezuela and
Cuba I can even hear Justin Trudeau
saying that in Canada fine it's fitting
America but they said that they said
that the cea but it's you you're not
free to put other people in danger wait
a minute but that's what that that's you
know and it wasn't me who said this it
was the leadership of these companies
well listen there's a lot of people now
that are sitting there saying you force
some people to take it they had they had
repercussion side effects it affected a
lot of people negatively and you forced
it in for us to sit there and say with a
hundred percent that it was the right
move to make with only nine months of
data that they had I think that's a
little naive now don't get me wrong we
can sit there and look at certain
vaccines and say okay like you know some
some people like none of them you got to
go I'm saying that there's certain ones
like listen that we have 30 years of
research on them holy yeah yeah we have
do you realize what that did do you know
what to say do you know how many people
you know we didn't have 30 years I
totally get that but that's the point
though the point of saying we didn't
have 30 years is more of a reason to say
it's a choice you either take it or you
don't take it wow it's just disagree I
know that's okay we disagree all I'm
saying is that the part where
when you say I don't like what Tucker
did Tucker spoke to a lot of people that
were part of that camp you know how many
people in the military that love America
that love being a marine they love being
you know a Navy or Air Force or Army
were forced to leave their jobs they
love you know how many people nobody
forced them to leave oh they had no
choice no your choice was to take the
vaccine
correct that's foreign
absolutely yeah and that's a and that's
a good thing you think that's a good
thing 100 okay so let me go to a
different direction because this first
thing is trending a lot lately what do
you think about ESG and will BlackRock
Vanguard and State Street is doing I I
that's a so completely different but
that's not an expert in that I don't
know okay you're not following this I
mean I I'm vaguely aware of it but it's
not something you have an opinion on not
really so then let's go back to this so
you're okay with
us of forcing something like that on
somebody so here's what's like we force
we we you your kid can't go to school
unless it's got the measles vaccine or
the polio not all schools this is why
somebody believe and they can get
religious exemptions and I get it and
those vaccines are also tested whereas
the foreign
what do you say to this so on my show
today I have a captain Army Captain
Katie Hernandez coming on my show they
told her if you don't get this vaccine
you are getting kicked out of the
military they forced her she went to the
she went to the Capitol Hill and they
they made her take it guess what she has
right now myocarditis Pat she's driving
in the car and she felt like she had a
heart attack heart attack what do you
say to those people that were forced to
do it because it's the government and
now she is suffering she has heart
problems because of something like that
because you don't you don't know that
the the vaccine caused her but they're
saying they said it they said that I
don't believe it okay
she's a healthy 25 year old girl by the
way by the way you also don't know that
it didn't I don't so but the point is
that both of us could be right or wrong
that's the choice you could be right I
could be except the the vast weight of
scientific evidence was behind vaccines
okay so uh not necessarily because we
didn't have a lot of debate anybody that
had an opposing argument they got
silence there were doctors out of
Bakersfield these two doctors that they
got up there and they gave their
argument the video got 20 million views
first 24 hours of videos all of them
were taken down they couldn't even give
these are doctors yeah these are medical
professionals that were supposed to
respect you couldn't have an opposing
argument so again let me give you the
leaks in this argument for a guy like me
that I've been a registered independent
for probably 20 years who liked Clinton
and I voted for Clinton but I voted both
sides of the island as well hey when I
sit there and I think about for me uh if
I uh uh uh have a a girl pregnant and I
chose to have unprotected sex with this
girl and it's my responsibility when I
had unprotected sex for me I'm gonna sit
there and say hey
I took responsibility I didn't have
condom I was excited we had sex you're
pregnant whatever you choose to do I
support it I'd support you having a baby
but your body you got to do whatever you
got to do but if you want to have the
baby I got for a lifetime I'm gonna take
care of this kid I'm in okay great
that's my position but for me to not
listen to what women are saying is
important to them that's arrogant who
the hell am I to not listen to their
argument what do you mean no you should
do this no I'm a Christian man I
understand what my positions for my
faith may be but I have to hear you out
for your argument and it's not like it's
20 of women saying this it's not like
it's eight percent a woman saying this
it's in the 60s now you see some places
say 40 50 60 it's 67 some places we've
seen all these numbers I have to hear
them out right so
the part where there's contradictions in
the argument is why are you forcing
women to have an abortion let them have
the choice then why are you forcing me
to take the vaccine this is when the
contradictions exposes hypocrisy and
there's leaks in the argument and an
independent guy like me that's purely
logical data driven that's just kind of
like I want to hear both sides of the
argument my mother was a communist my
dad was an imperialist my entire life it
was about debate I mean they really
great dinner talk no no that's what I
listened to one thought rich people were
greedy the other one thought poor people
were lazy this was the argument in my
life that I had to listen to for 20
years so for me I want to hear both
sides and I say you know what the guys
that don't want to take the vaccine I
think you have a valid point I totally
respect it so I was my board and the
investors one time they're like well
Patrick we have to have were you on this
I don't know if you were on this maybe
immediately prior to me yeah because I
know who you're talking we had this we
had this board meeting and emergency
board meeting we didn't talk to Patrick
I'm the ceiling the chairman okay yes
hey um
what's your position on getting your
guys to get vaccinated what do you mean
are you going to get your guys
vaccinated a lot of the guys are and
some of them are not okay so are you
thinking about sending somebody for
these guys who take the vaccinations so
what do you mean how about if we pay to
send somebody to offices to get
everybody vaccinated that's yeah it's
not my style it's not what we started a
company for well let me tell you what it
is if you come into a Citigroup
everybody's vaccinated if we're going to
go meet with these investment bankers
that are thinking about buying our
company or visiting to our company you
have to be vaccinated or you can't go
into the meeting so we use the
technology that you and I don't like
Zoom is what we use okay so we had these
meetings with these people and said oh
let me tell you this so okay we can only
have the meeting there all right no
problem uh for preferably I'm a
face-to-face guy I want to sit with you
and talk to you you know what I
eventually did I mentioned made a video
and I say guys
some of you guys are going to like this
video some of you guys are not going to
like this video
my recommendation to you all is the
following if you're vaccinated Don't
Force the other side or judge them if
they're still going through the process
of thinking about getting vaccinated if
you are not vaccinated don't judge the
other people that chose to get
vaccinated if you're wondering where I'm
at my wife and I and our kids are not
yet vaccinated but my dad who is
conservative like at the highest level
like I'm talking like super conservative
guy
he's not only vaccinated he's got four
boosters and my nanny who is not our
Nanny anymore she's like a grandmother
because she's been with us for 15 years
like this woman whatever she wants
everything's on me I take care of this
lady she got vaccinated and she has all
the boosters both of them do so it's not
a dad why'd you do this it's dude what
do you want to do salute this is what
we're doing so the part about Tucker
that you're talking about
I think he tapped into an audience that
was also relating to not want it to be
forced and they want a choice so I think
there's a little bit of leaks in the
argument of it's the right move to make
to force people to take the vaccine
that's all I'm saying I I
you know as with a lot of issues I know
a lot of people don't agree with me yeah
and that's fine yeah I mean I I you know
I I'm not I I you know this is one of
you know it's interesting about why
people get into journalism and
um I I when I used to work at the New
Yorker I I would
um there was a very elaborate
fact-checking process and the fact
gestures tended to be young and kind of
idealistic and and this scene often
often happened would happen I'd write
about a controversial thing and
sometimes a fact Checker would say to me
you know when your story comes out what
do you think is going to happen
and and they said you know what do you
think is going to happen and and I said
you know what's going to happen people
will read it and they'll go hmm
interesting
and that's all that's fine I mean that's
all I I wanted out of out of my
journalism I am not someone who you know
writes and goes on TV or writes books
because I want to change the world I
want to tell stories that are
interesting that are thought provocative
I have certain opinions I have an
opinion about vaccines but you know
other people disagree I'm not you know
that's fine I might say this too though
but I got to say this to you yeah we've
never broke bread we've never had a
conversation the first time you and I
met was two hours ago correct right my
experience with you of these two hours
I've enjoyed my experience with you I
have respect for the fact that you can
come here and you're respectful if I'm
given a different side some things we
agree on some things we disagree on your
way of handling that is super respectful
and I applaud you for that I got a lot
of respect for people that can do that I
think we need more of this because I
think at the end of the day you know who
won on today's show not you not me the
people that are watching this right they
get to sit there and say he made a good
point they get to sit there and say I
disagree they get to Pat I agree I
disagree I they get to do that part
that's all we can do simple is that a
great conversation to finish up to
finish up to finish up the whole thing
here I want to get into the book with
the last five minutes that we have
homegrown Timothy McVeigh and the rise
of right-wing extremism uh what is the
premise behind this book and why did you
choose to write this
um
the Oklahoma City bombing was April 19
1995.
um two years later uh McVeigh and
Nichols went on trial the trial was
moved to Denver
um and I covered the trial I was then
working for ABC and The New Yorker so I
I you know I I was well steeped in the
story but you know time had passed and
you know I never wrote a book about it
in October of 2020 uh right before the
election
um the FBI arrested a group of people
um who were plotting to kidnap Governor
Whitmer of Michigan and Terry Nichols
who was the co-defendant in that case
was also for Michigan he was affiliated
with the Michigan militia same same with
the uh
um the uh the the people who were
involved in in the kidnapping and I
thought wow this is like you know
similar January 6 happened a few weeks
later so I decided to look at the story
again first of all it's just an
incredible true crime story of how
McVeigh did this and and I certainly
believe that McVay did do it it's not
like there's some conspiracy that he
didn't do it he certainly did it and and
the way he organized it and the way he
you know got the fertilizer and the J in
the in the
um racing fuel and rented the truck it's
just an incredible story but
um McVeigh has since been portrayed as
um someone who was like a lone wolf and
an anti-government person it's not
accurate McVeigh was part of the
right-wing movement of the 90s he was
um someone who was a you know a big Rush
Limbaugh supporter he was a Pat Buchanan
supporter he was
um someone who was obsessed with um the
the supposed fear that the government
was going to take his guns away if you
see that ideology moving forward
um that ideology is it has been enduring
and the difference is that McVeigh
didn't have the internet in the 90s he
didn't have the ability to communicate
with like-minded people and
um
those sorts of views are com are a lot
easier to spread now and if you look at
whether it's January 6th or the mass
Shooters in El Paso and South Carolina
in Pittsburgh in Buffalo they are all
mobilized by the internet in a way that
McVeigh couldn't and I want to let
Vinnie talk now because I know he thinks
I'm so foolish I I think you you left
out that McVeigh was a psychotic
murdering Mania he's he's absolutely to
do something like that to kill all those
people you're insane I do agree listen
January 6 some idiots went there and
they did some stupid [__] but one person
died and it was actually bad but she was
a United States military veteran who was
shot and killed and we just found out
again through all the Twitter files how
many FBI agents were down there
basically and I saw the video of Roy
apps it literally yeah follow us
undercover FBI agents hadn't been there
January 6th how many more would have
been killed no but what I'm saying is
yelling at people inciting violence and
writing from Agents on the floor agents
let's let's just be honest with each
other pushing people in to go do it one
person died and here's my question Jeff
can you blame can you blame a group of
people that know for a fact that they
already tried to get cheated on on
January 6 I'm sorry uh 2016 election
they know that uh Hillary and everybody
tried to cheat to get Trump out that was
100 cheating why would you blame them to
think that in 2020 they wouldn't try it
again so can you blame people for not
trusting a system and then going
somewhere because I believe in this if
you have a problem with the system you
don't burn down your city you don't do a
BLM did you don't do what antifa does
with your actual terrorists antifa are
domestic terrorists you don't burn down
your city you go to the heart those
people some of them stupid as hell I
agree some of them vandalizing and
beating [__] out of people but when you
have a problem with the system you don't
burn down your city you go to the system
you go to the government and they did
that and I hold on and get it when
people say threat to democracy I I don't
believe that that was a threat to
democracy I think that was a bunch of
pissed off people that were screwed once
and they believed I don't believe it or
not they were like you know what I think
we got cheated again and then went to
the heart of the stores the the
protests are completely legitimate and
that's as an American as apple pie
protest but
it's it's not it's not legal or
appropriate or in any way defensible to
break into the case
absolutely and that's why we're talking
about I mean we're only talking about
the people in the capital we're not
talking about the people at the
economics who were at Trump's rally you
know yeah and also I think you know we
don't know exactly what went on behind
the scenes but I don't think you can
prosecute Trump for what he said in that
speech he said you got a fight every
politician says you got to fight right
that's not the Beastie Boys said you got
to fight for your right yes indeed and
who could disagree with that
because you do have to fight for your
arrest and this is why Vinnie I told you
but when you went to January
but but
um you know the the difference is
crimes committed and you know you can't
commit crimes that that's the that's
what's
um that's you know what to me is
indefensible and you know you obviously
you know McVeigh did something far more
egregious but the engaging in violence
and support of your political position
is something that has carried forward I
agree because I think it listen anybody
only one side
far oh and this is this is something
that I you know I deal with in the book
this fantasy that antifa is somehow as
dangerous as the right is is a com is is
a if you look at the statistics 75 of
the political crimes in this country
have been committed by people on the
right antifa is a tiny tiny percentage
compared to to that
I mean from what I've seen every time
the right is trying to do something or
speak or protest or have talk antifa
shows up just to cause havoc and shut
them down because again you have to
silence in Portland and hardly enough
they just went to Glendale and they were
in Glendale California because Armenian
people were like you're not going to
teach our kids all this stuff they're
underage antifa was there and they got
their asses by The Armenian community
and I salute them I get messages left
and right facts support what you're
saying with the 75 it's in the book yeah
okay you said who cares about the facts
I'm gonna read this book yeah I'm gonna
take this book
political political crimes is what you
just said can you break that down I know
what a violent crime is I know what
aggravated assault is when you say
political crimes politically motivated
crimes
crimes you know that that you know like
um the the uh Muslim extremists who shot
up uh I forgot which word it was uh the
one of the army bases the the
psychiatrist in Maryland Texas Fort Hood
I mean that was a politically motivated
crime it was you know Islamic terrorism
um right calling that from the right no
not at all I'm saying I'm drawing this
distinction yeah I'm saying it was not
from the right that if you there there
is crimes from Islamic terrorists there
are crimes from the uh the left antifa
and their crimes from the right people
like the white supremacists who shot up
the Walmart in El Paso the
um Dylan roof who killed the people in
South Carolina church the uh Anderson
shooting in the synagogue the grocery
store in in Buffalo those are from the
right that that's those are the sort of
three General categories I'm talking
about and what would you what would you
say because I mean we hear we hear it
all the time from from the left from the
White House from Joe Biden that the
number one threat to the United States
is is white supremacy it's it's those
and and that's what that's what the
numbers show that that's where most of
the most of the threat comes from
because we have mother we had two FBI
whistleblowers here and I asked them the
very same question you know what they
both said it ain't it ain't white
supremacies that he's like it's the
actual Insider threat and he goes it's
the government against the people and
that's these guys they were sitting
right where we're sitting right now and
they said that that's what the threat
was he said the percentage these are FBI
agents that the percentage of white
white supremists walking around causing
problems that's that's not the that's
not the number one problem here so wow
you know if the audience wants to find
out for themselves on the opposing
argument or something they agree with
they can order the book home grown the
Link's gonna be below for you guys to
order once again uh thank you so much
for coming out and being on the podcast
absolutely terrific thank you all your
terrific group and I really am grateful
for the opportunity you've been a very
good sport at no idea how you were going
to be but you've been a good sport and I
respect that and again go to the book
Link's gonna be below thanks everybody
take care bye bye-bye packing